mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur und
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
ja
wir kommen auf den kulturplatz wir
sprechen heute über ein leid das uns
alle treffen kann
das statistische abends meldet bereits
vor vier jahren habe sich ein drittel
der menschen in unserem land einsam
gefühlt wir können nur erahnen was die
korona krise mit diesen zahlen macht
darüber wollen wir nachdenken und zwar
hier oben in der einsamkeit der natur am
herzen
[Musik]
ja was ist sie eigentlich die einsamkeit
ein gefühl ein zustand an schicksal
ein amerikanischer socio neurologe
verglich die einsamkeit mit einem hummer
mit dem gefühl also das uns daran
erinnert zu essen
nur was tun wenn niemand da ist uns zu
nähren
in zeiten der sozialen distanz hat die
einsamkeit hochkonjunktur
wir zeigen wege mit ihr umzugehen
einsamkeit kennen alle künstler also
auch tänzer
[Musik]
wir werden dann etwas authentisch
bringen möchte dann muss man auch sich
selbst einladen man bisher in dieser
einsamkeit zu kaufen
[Musik]
aller von unser leben heute einsamkeit
entweder verspürt man sie selbst oder
man erlebt mit wie freunde
familienmitglieder oder
arbeitskolleginnen und kollegen mit der
einsamkeit in diesen zeiten
die neue empathie die neue nähe das
darin liegen soll dass man anderen vom
leib bleibt und ich fürchte und vor
allem je länger dieser zustand dauert
und wir haben ja nun fast seit einem
jahr
je länger dieser zustand dauert desto
mehr wird mir spürbar dass es ein
solches paradox das hält der mensch auf
dauer nicht aus wie ist es wenn einen
die einsamkeit in pandemie zeiten völlig
unerwartet trifft das erzählt die
deutsche schriftstellerin thea darin in
ihrem neuen roman trost briefe an max es
ist die geschichte von johanna einer
erfolgreichen philosophin lebensbejahend
und lustig ihre 84-jährige mutter steckt
sich auf einer italienreise mit dem
virus an und stirbt kurze zeit später
johanna darf nicht ans krankenbett ein
einsamer tod
die tatsache dass man angehörige
gehindert hat ihre sterbenden liebsten
zu begleiten ist für mich der größte
skandal der im zuge der pandemie
bekämpfung passiert ist weil das sterben
die zone ist wo wir menschen an den rand
unseres witzes an den rand unseres
könnens kommen was soll man da klug
daher reden da habe ich für mich sehr
schnell gewusst ich kann mich nur den
gefühlen derjenigen überlassen der so
etwas passiert ist und dass es glaubt
wiwo in meinem roman
johanna allein zurückgeblieben
überfordert von dieser zeit in der
mitgefühl distanz bedeutet schreibt
ihrem alten freund max briefe sie
erzählt von der beerdigung eine umarmung
und von den maßnahmen die sie zwar nötig
und zugleich unaufhaltbar findet ich war
auf der suche danach auszudrücken genau
diese diese ambivalenz zu sagen es gibt
den einen tag wo ich da sitzen und
denken natürlich diese maßnahmen sind
alle sinnvoll und das müssen wir jetzt
einfach durchhalten und schluss mit dem
gejammer wie schlimm diese maßnahmen
sind und dann höre ich wieder
geschichten von leuten die seit monaten
wirklich wirklich einsam in ihren
wohnungen sitzen weil sie nicht das
glück haben in der partnerschaft zu
leben oder eine familie zu haben
häufig wird die einsamkeit bei älteren
menschen verortet neueste zahlen zeigen
die pandemie hat das subjektive
einsamkeit empfinden von über 65
jährigen verstärkt
[Musik]
überraschenderweise sind dabei vor allem
auch die jungen von einsamkeit betroffen
bei den 15 bis 24 jährigen fühlt sich
laut bundesamt für statistik fast jede
und jeder zweite einsam
die britische wirtschaftsprofessorin
arena hart sagt einsamkeit das soziale
problem des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts auf die idee sich mit den
einsamen zu beschäftigen kam sie weil
ihre studierenden oft von einsamkeit
gefühlen berichteten
was mich bei meinen recherchen am
meisten überrascht hat
die jungen sind die einsamsten in
unserer gesellschaft in den vereinigten
staaten hat einer von fünf millennials
keinen einzigen freund im vereinigten
königreich fühlen sich drei viertel der
unter 15-jährigen oft oder immer einsatz
das sind schockierende zahlen sie
untersucht in ihrem neuen buch das
zeitalter der einsamkeit die globalen
auswirkungen dieses gefühl von
verlorenheit einsamkeit schadet unserer
gesundheit so stark wie wenn man 15
zigaretten pro tag rauchen würde
das liegt daran dass wir nicht dafür
geschaffen sind allein zu sein
vielleicht ist dieses aktuelle
kollektive experiment der isolation eine
gute sache damit wir mehr über
einsamkeit sprechen und die menschen zu
geben können wie schwer es ist sich
isoliert zu fühlen
ein ort an dem einsamkeit gelindert wird
ist das café joker mitten in zürich
die beratungs und anlaufstelle empfängt
menschen in schwierigen lebenslagen das
café kann mit wenigen gästen auch in der
pandemie offen bleiben
das ist doch tom wichtig
also jetzt personen sind wirklich zwei
jahre am stück
die treffe ich hier täglich und das
macht einfach spaß da auch aus zu 1000
oder miteinander mal einzelkauf
kinopolis da heißt dass ich langsamer
schweiz vorfreude in der gaststube wird
der unterschied klar
allein sein dafür kann man sich aktiv
entscheiden
einsamkeit kann niemand wählen pandemie
einsam sie erzählte wie sie ihren alltag
verbringen wenn sie vor ihre bedürfnisse
erzählen
sehen sie sich auch noch mit partner
oder partnerin da merkt man schon dass
sie einsam sind zurzeit steigt das
bedürfnis nach beratungen an
jetzt wo alles geschlossen ist bietet
das café joker weiterhin ein wenig
gemeinschaft und austausch eine kleine
oase in der die einsamkeit vor der tür
bleibt eine ganz andere welt ist die der
kultur aber auch hier in der tanzszene
ist das einsam seiner thema die
internationale kompanie fungiert deshalb
als ersatzfamilie
doch die fällt jetzt ganz weg ohne
konkrete auftrittsmöglichkeit wird nicht
mehr weiter geprobt
es ist unser letzter tag im studio und
es wird sicher auch noch mal ein
emotionaler moment für uns alle
jetzt haben wir zwei sehr starke
produktionen bis bis zur generalprobe
geprobt so dass wenn wir wieder das
theater aufmachen dürfen wir sozusagen
fast unmittelbar bereit sind auch etwas
zeigen zu können ab jetzt würde es
tatsächlich auch keinen sinn machen
weiter zu produzieren das wäre eine
verschwendung von ressourcen die zeit
die für die einsamen so schwierig ist
dauert an
maritim opi hat für sich einen weg
gefunden mit der einsamkeit umzugehen
versuche auch die schöne sache in dieser
ausnahmesituation zu finden
mal hoffentlich erleben wir das alles
nur einmal und
dann können wir zurückschauen vielleicht
zehn jahren dann bleibt ja auch noch
etwas übrig das positiv ist
[Musik]
sabine posse mit rache der natur sie
sind der geschäftsführerin von der
dargebotenen hand wie viel sprach 4c
unter dem titel einsamkeit
also wir haben im 20
musik sprache führt zum thema einsamkeit
und das sind über sieben prozent mix aus
dem 2000 nutzer das machte bei zwei sich
sprachlos die franz und das sind also
bei 5 pro tag angerechnet achim er als
ruhig
das heißt es hat der klare zunahme game
letzte als hätte klar zu einer umkehr
und einsamkeit könnte wirklich zu einem
top trio themen und es ist sicher einer
unterschätzt will das schwingt wie ganz
viele andere sprache es um andere themen
gott also zwischen der ziele mit könnten
die betroffenen telefon sagen ich bin
einsam das ist ja mit sehr viel charme
selbst als ich das überhaupt keine ins
gestand das kommt praktisch nicht vor
will einsamkeit einzig wirklich ein
thema das stigma da kommt niemand zeit
ich bin allein sondern dass geräte da
und sagen dass gold mine geholt und in
212 erzähler und eben weil nach unten
oder den punkten saitenspiel sich neben
ruhm bin ich irgendwann nicht mehr
besucher ich an meine eltern verloren
oder was auch immer oder was brauchen
die menschen am dringensten als
verrückte nicht aber man stellt sich
dann überlegen wir die alten einsamen
vor oder und das kommt allen
bevölkerungsschichten und auch die
beiden geschlechter sich vor die
mannschaft wird gern gesehen und
verstanden werden und darum haben sie
wenn man innere beziehung ist mit der
familie machen sich furchtbar an
gefühlen oder sich einsam fühlen als
managerin einer top-position im rolli
entschuldigen muss aber viele junge
menschen sind einsam überall vernetzung
social media tochter wie sie niemand
sagen wie es mir wirklich gott oder was
redet dann die jungen alters hsb über
das ich als telefongespräch ja das ist
das telefongespräch und kein kompetenz
wie viel sie untereinander walsmann
und genau warum schaffen wir aber mit
freiwillige und damit fachpersonen wie
das ist von mensch zu mensch auf
augenhöhe
das heißt es braucht in erster linie es
gegenüber
es braucht es gar keine über wo wirklich
gespielt wo ganz bei mir bin ich ruhig
verzweifelten wo bin ich allein und das
wagner werden als mensch das ist im
zentrum und das für das buch greift
personen so mancher war einfach sehr
sympathisch renzi
was kann gesellschaft mache was
rentieren die ich mache aus
privatpersonen
ich finde das nicht so einfach wenn man
es so ca verantwortlich für das was
weniger einsamkeit unserer gesellschaft
geht wie dem individuum zwischen auf der
gesellschaftlichen ebene läuft in andere
richtig und trifft sich nehmen einfach
so auf dem dorfplatz oderbruch staaten
haltestellen oder und das feld immer
mehr weg- oder und gesellschaftlich der
druck war es wichtig dass wir über neue
wohnformen danket all die silos mit
weniger wo jeder widerlegen ist was ist
hier die perspektiven für das ja mit was
rechnen ich nehme während mit
sprechanlage hier das image des 20
speziell sie ob sie das hängt damit
zusammen dass man kapazitäten erweitert
hat wie man es wichtig dass man mehr um
hand mit sieht das gespräch
[Musik]
ein coming out zu wahren das braucht
auch heute noch mut in deutschland wagen
dies aktuell 185 schauspielerinnen und
schauspieler gemeinsam
man stelle sich also vor wie unmöglich
einkommen out vor 200 jahren war
diesen einsamen kampf wohl auch der
polnische komponist frederic chopin
geführt denn es gibt neue erkenntnisse
die darauf hinweisen dass super heimlich
einen mann liebte mein liebstes leben
ist mir nie so gefehlt wie jetzt beim
ibu gibt einen kulanten clips träge
liebt vom ihre liebe zu frauen starteten
jene tipis was überliefert ist dass er
so viel liebe jährige ammann thc bevor
amadeus wojciechowski
du liebst der tito satten grün seine
lenden an dem du sagst ich solle dich
küssen habe ich reiten vor deiner sagt
für immer friedrich schupp an was wohl
das ist die klare ansage von srf
musikredakteur moritz weber niemand hat
das bisher so wirklich ausdrücklich
explizit formuliert die morgens weber
seine recherchen die er in der
radiosendung passage publik machte haben
für schlagzeilen gesorgt weltweit sehr
kontrovers wurden sie im katholisch
geprägten polen wo chopard als national
komponist verehrt wird diskutiert das
bestätigt kulturwissenschaftlerin dort
als erster von der uni zürich
natürlich es gibt also liberale
zeitungen wie zb gazeta wyborcza wurde
zb festgestellt dass alles was jetzt
moritz weber auch uns gesagt hat war uns
schon seit langem ganz klar
andererseits natürlich gibt es ja auch
so rechtskonservative pressen oder die
politiker die zum beispiel sagen dass
jetzt dieses dieser faule westen wild
wie wird wieder also unserer unserer
geschichte auch beschmutzen wollen
während des shutdown letzten frühling
nahm sich moritz weber chopins
briefsammlung zur brust
1200 seiten auf französisch
er studierte die korrespondenz auch auf
deutsch und englisch lernte sogar
polnisch bei der lektüre diverser
übersetzungen machten in fußnoten die
auf frauengeschichten hinweisen stutzig
quellenangaben
fehlanzeige
er ließ abschnitte der originalbriefe
mehrfach von experten neu übersetzen
fazit etliche pronomen entsprachen in
bezug aufs geschlecht bis dato nicht dem
original übersetzung wovon einer
ehemaligen professor gemacht wurde sind
die hand tätig relativ gravierende
fehler von männlicher pronomen es wie
brecht das super institut in warschau
spricht von interpretation und
kulturelle überlieferung die pronomen
müssten sich nicht zwingend auf den
brief empfänger beziehen ein paar
absetzen wo das wirklich nicht eindeutig
ist der professor david fray das
bakterium university hat sich
entschieden auf basis seiner kenntnis
des kulturellen kontext und tradition es
so zu machen
der einzige der bis dato attestierte das
opfer eine homosexuelle affäre mit titus
wolterhoff ski gehabt haben könnte ist
der renommierte biograf ian walker
allerdings fügte er ein großes aber
hinzu
das hat mich so erstaunt dass in der
biografie zeit tochter statt das egal ob
von einem mental twist oder psychische
für dreieck und dass er die
liebeserklärung und erotisch es auch
eine spezielle einer frau geschrieben
hat ich werde gleich fräulein maria
besuchen du weißt dass das meine liebe
laien sind zu denen ich mich gerne
bekenne man muss den deckmantel der
versteckten gefühle schon
trotz solcher bekenntnisse hält man in
traditionellen kreisen daran fest dass
shop als erster große liebe die sängerin
konstant sehr gut koska gewesen sein
soll
sie hat alle briefe von the band um
ihren job einfach verbrannt
außerdem sei mit maria winzker verlobt
und mit der französischen
schriftstellerin george sand liiert
gewesen
[Musik]
das hat sich zeigt dass für die
angebliche affäre zu frauen das ist okay
es gibt briefe wurde schon bald in
marokko hat und auch von titus
wojciechowski die sind alle verschwunden
und ich finde das ist einfach ein
kritischer faktor sind buch ist webers
schlussfolgerung kann in polen wo
präsident angelo dagegen alle nicht
heterosexuellen hetzt als kampfansage
gelesen werden oder aber als
schützenhilfe für die kur bewegung
das was jetzt auf den straßen passiert
ist ja auch der beweis nicht nur von der
gewalt von den rechts konservativen
sondern auch von der mut und auch von
der kraft von allen anderen die für ein
anderes polen auch kämpfen ob in der
lgbt gegenwart oder in der
kirchengeschichte in beide scheint jetzt
bewegung zu kommen
was dann auch selber gemacht es ist
unsere gegner es ein bisschen mehr zu
recherchieren und jetzt glaube ich wir
brauchen nicht nur die
musikwissenschaftler aber auch wieder
habe ich sowieso schach
dazu sollten wir gute klima des
spezialisten auch bringen
dann könnten sie was neues sagen moritz
weber hat einen stein ins rollen
gebracht
auf neues des nationalhelden spannend
sind wir gespannt
[Musik]
unsere reihe kultur kick gibt kultur
schaffen dann eine chance die momentan
ihr publikum nicht erreichen so wie etwa
die basler band frag nicht sie musste
schon zweimal ihre plattentaufe
verschieden jetzt wird sie bei uns
gefeiert
glasklar reduziert und doch tanzbar
[Musik]
die band frag nicht aus basel liebt und
lebt den sound der 1980 er jahre
[Musik]
wer hier an den legendären eisbär der
schweizer band grauzone denkt liegt
nicht ganz falsch
damals in den 80ern war sie hoch im kurs
die neue deutsche welle mit bands wie
ideal oder split doch frag nicht hat
vielfältige inspirationsquellen 1 der
erste single sowie der halloween aktion
die deutsche musik ist ich bin einfach
so mit menschen manny marc o polo hofer
noser die batteriespannung polo hofer
es ist jedoch strikt sie in der fähre
werde musik bestehen im alter und die
musikbühne eigentlich mehr
ich hoffe ihr versteht von kanam in
steinort werde muss ich zugeben war
jetzt nicht so meine musikrichtung aber
wenn ich glaube dass das tor aber ein
dass das sich so viel mehr steigen wir
und dann nachher kommt was daraus als
konsens kunde hand die vier wollen mit
ihrer musik aber mehr als nur ihr
publikum bespaßen
als berg ist ein klares statement zur
klimaerwärmung mit einem appell
[Musik]
das ist einfach bei uns schwer bis das
klima thema wohl mehr werden will
das ist sowieso unserem herz liegt dass
man so tragen zu unserem rat und das
muss jetzt handeln
die cd und vier songs war im vergangenen
sommer fertig zweimal schon musste die
band die plattentaufe mit konzert
absagen
[Musik]
stattdessen dachten sie sich etwas
besonderes aus
ursprünglich lag die deko fotomodel
einer webseite nicht einfach so simple
platte darf nach dem sinn vor mit
prosecco flasche und cdh oder und
promoter biscayne stadt die
installationen von peter fischli david
weiss dass lauf der dinge
eine bahnbrechende arbeit der schweizer
medienkünstler fischli weiss und dann
habe ich mir das projekt hat gute idee
und not ist noch einfacher von baustahl
und plan aber ich habe keine erfahrung
also das ist einfach alles entstanden
gerade mal 50 leute durften im november
bei ihrer kunst installation dabei sein
ohne live musik versteht sich
[Musik]
das stundenlange tüfteln im estrich hat
sich gelohnt
[Musik]
alles läuft wie am schnürchen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dem exklusiven kreis der damals
zugelassenen hat es gefallen aber eben
die musik nur aus der konserve gibt es
der jetzt noch eine richtige
plattentaufe und wann wird es denn
endlich wieder live musik
[Musik]
alles klar wir fragen nicht mehr
aber hoffen dürfen wir ja
[Musik]
das war unser spaziergang in der stille
der natur und hier oben habe ich darüber
sinniert wie sehr wir alle das
alleinsein immer wieder brauchen um ganz
bei uns anzukommen
die einsamkeit dagegen sie ist nie
selbst gewählt nächste woche da begrüßt
sie meine kollegin nina meyer wies
brunner und trifft einen renommierten
klimaforscher und wir wir sehen uns im
märz wieder alles liebe
[Musik]
b
ja
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos
[Musik]